I'd like to show you a simple argument
for the fact that Pi is equal to 4 we
start off with a circle say with radius
1 and we ask how can we figure out its
circumference after all Pi is by
definition the ratio of this
circumference to the diameter of the
circle we start off by drawing the
square whose side lengths are all
tangent to that Circle it's not too hard
to see that the perimeter of this square
is eight then the argument proceeds by
producing a sequence of Curves all of
whom also have this perimeter of eight
but which more and more closely
approximate the circle and there are all
sorts of examples throughout calculus
when we talk about approximating one
thing we want to know as a limit of a
bunch of other things that are easier to
understand so the question at the heart
here is why exactly is it not okay to do
that in this
example